let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well we knew this
for a long time
and it's just not
on gun violence gun reform
and back doors on schools
we've known that ted cruz is a [ __ ]
coward for a very very very long time
this is not news
i mean i typed it out this morning i'm
like yeah
of course
of course ted cruz is a [ __ ] coward
and greg abbott and the rest of the gop
with them
and again like i said yesterday that has
to be our one issue folks you are now
one issue voters right now you are one
issue voters and that's [ __ ] the gop
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them
that's your that's your [ __ ] one
issue
they want guns to have more rights than
the uterus
they want to ban back doors he wants he
wants to ban
back doors that's his solution
to children being slaughtered in schools
schools are already [ __ ] locking
their back doors they're creating entire
entrances just because of guns
not because of people the [ __ ]
gun it's the gun you [ __ ] dummy
they build entire entrances on schools
to make sure that a gun doesn't get past
a certain door
and ted cruz and they lock the back
doors
they lock them [ __ ] they take the
handles off of them at my daughter's
school there are no handles on the
outside of the back doors no handles not
a goddamn handle you couldn't open that
door if you wanted to
unless you propped it open
like happens it happens
oh if you just lock back doors children
won't get shot you know after going in
and out of the school that's never
happened before ever in the history of
ever ever
ted cruz is a [ __ ] coward and he's
not a dumb [ __ ] i mean i wish i could
call him a dumb [ __ ] and most the time
when he does say some of this [ __ ] it
sounds like he's a dumb [ __ ] but it's
because he's a god damn coward and he
will not stand up
for children in texas he will not stand
up for the parents of those children in
texas
he will not stand up for women
he won't even stand up for his own
goddamn wife
he wouldn't even stand up for his
[ __ ] wife
and we expect this [ __ ] to
protect our children
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
backdoor [ __ ]
same guy wanted to ban dildos in texas
banned dildos in women's healthcare and
backdoors what in the actual [ __ ] are
you talking about
you coward ass [ __ ] you punk ass
[ __ ] ted cruz
and yesterday
during the nra presser because that's
what it was folks
at the uvalde high school where greg
abbott and lieutenant governor dan
patrick and the mayor of
uvalde and ted cruz
went and gave their nra presser i i said
it during the [ __ ] presser we played
it live on the air go to the youtube
channel and watch the end of the episode
we played it we showed beto handing them
their ass on live on air
we clipped it out and put a clip on our
youtube channel you can go watch it over
there
at the nra presser ted cruz
is very nervous
very [ __ ] nervous when bet o'rourke
starts telling them to do their [ __ ]
job do your [ __ ] job [ __ ]
you're not here to protect the gun lobby
you're not here to protect the gun
manufacturers you're here to work for
the [ __ ] people and that mayor
that old ass [ __ ] fat old
[ __ ] mayor of uvalde oh [ __ ]
you talk about vote that [ __ ]
out
it is political [ __ ] you don't mean to
be doing politics in this forum it is
political [ __ ] and we're gonna
politic all over your goddamn ass
democrats need to grow some [ __ ] nuts
here just like beto had yesterday it's
enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're
like oh well we can't we can't oh we got
a soft hand
we got a light glove [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's
politics [ __ ]
we're gonna politic all up and down this
[ __ ] nation
all up and down your [ __ ] asses
it's enough of this [ __ ]
i'm tired of hearing about children
in schools
people in grocery stores
parishioners in churches
children on the street being killed by
[ __ ] guns it's the gun you dumb
[ __ ]
there are no good guys
there's no good guys
there are none
and the ones that you claim are good
guys with guns we find out there's
there's a lot of conflicting reports
but apparently
apparently
those police officers in uvalde
stood outside were more concerned about
blocking the parents from their children
than to save the children from the
gunman
absolutely [ __ ] disgusting
we're gonna show the video here because
we do not look away here at the tony
michaels podcast no [ __ ] way in hell
are we gonna do that
we're gonna watch the [ __ ]
good guy bad guy [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here back doors get the [ __ ] out of
that [ __ ] they're locking the back doors
already cruz
you should be so [ __ ] embarrassed
that you should buy a [ __ ] another
plane ticket to cancun and [ __ ] stay
there
you piece of [ __ ] trash
are you with me are you with me
we're gonna politic all up and down this
[ __ ] politics politics politics
you goddamn right we're gonna win some
goddamn elections that's what we're
gonna [ __ ] do
that's how we're gonna solve this
problem
they ain't gonna do it for us you think
craig habit and ted cruz
and the lieutenant dan patrick and the
attorney general down in texas that
[ __ ] scumbag
you think these guys are gonna help us
fix the [ __ ] problem
greg abbott was cheering
cheering that more people could get guns
yay woohoo
an 18 year old then yuvali can get a gun
to go shoot up his school after he kills
his grant tries to kill his grandmother
yay
freedom
you gotta be out of your [ __ ] mind if
you don't think this is politics
you have to be out of your [ __ ] mind
if you do not think
that this is politics folks don't let
them [ __ ] trick you into that [ __ ]
ted cruz and they try oh you're just
trying to make politic you goddamn right
we're trying to make politics out of it
you goddamn right
today
you want to stack up dead bodies with
cord wood because you want to make sure
the gun manufacturers can sell more guns
we're damn sure going to make politics
out of that [ __ ]
we're gonna win some elections so we
don't have to stack up children like
[ __ ] cord wood we don't have to stack
up bodies out of grocery stores and
churches
who's with me
let's make the politics
out of politics out of politics out of
this [ __ ] them
they're just hoping will go away they'll
just hope and you will shut up
eventually i'll eventually these lip
shits these [ __ ] libs these liberals
these liptars they'll just quiet down
eventually
they'll quiet down don't worry about it
and then we'll keep winning elections
because we'll make politics at all kinds
of dumb [ __ ] like banning math
and banning back doors and banning
dildos and making sure women's
healthcare isn't accessible you know
[ __ ] like that
we'll make sure we can marry children
and shoot them in schools why not
it's time it's time folks for democrats
to do to do the
politics thing it's time
stop being such [ __ ] [ __ ] stop
being so cowardly like ted cruz
put your [ __ ] big big boy pants on
and play some politics like better
o'rourke did yesterday
that nra presser
no one's gonna remember a [ __ ] thing
those fascists said not a [ __ ] thing
those fascists said
the [ __ ] people are gonna even the right
wing this morning the right wing this
morning can't focus on anything but
better aurora's real [ __ ] name
they aren't playing clips of the nra
talking points from the presser they're
not playing clips they're saying oh
better
that's not his real name as if mitt
romney is his real name as if mitch
mcconnell is his real [ __ ] name
give me a [ __ ] break
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
as if his nickname has anything to do
with him standing up for people in texas
because that's what he did yesterday
we saw it and i'm going to show you the
video because yesterday we weren't able
to have the footage on the show
when he left the auditorium
after he basically told greg abbott to
go [ __ ] himself and do his job or shut
the [ __ ] up
and not so many words that's how i would
have put it
you know
beto might be more
or
less vulgar maybe you'd say than i am
but it is politics folks and we should
make politics out of it
because there's going to be a next one
there there's going to be another one
probably today maybe tomorrow
maybe two or three by the weekend who
the [ __ ] knows
it's america [ __ ] you could have two or
three of them in a day
more guns than people
and more mass shooting than days in this
country
because we
we the people who want reasonable gun
reform
reasonable gun safety [ __ ] that just yet
that's not even that [ __ ]
controversial background checks ninety
percent of the country's like yeah you
should probably make sure that [ __ ]
crazy people aren't grabbing guns that's
a thing you should probably do like you
should do your best at that
90
they're on our side
they're [ __ ]
on our side
and it's time to play the politics yeah
yep sure is
and we need to be one issue voters only
one issue only one
again i said it yesterday over and over
and over and i'm gonna keep repeating it
i'm gonna keep repeating myself i'm
gonna beat this into the [ __ ] brains
[ __ ] the gop
that's the one issue [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
it's my mantra
[ __ ] i put it on hats [ __ ] them
it's now time
to play politics in this country
democrats need to stop being such
[ __ ] wimps
then you stop crying about [ __ ] and all
this stuff [ __ ] it do what beto did
yesterday and go right after him right
after him where it hurts
right after their pride and their
[ __ ] theater
because that's what he did yesterday he
snatched the entire [ __ ] theater away
from them
snatched it away from him
we have to do this all over the country
folks and it's not just the politicians
that have to do this i mean we can force
them to do this
we can keep forcing them to do this by
rewarding them when they do it
listen listen to me when i say this this
is the politics because see we get
things confused in this country
there's politics and there's government
and everyone wants to yell and scream
about policy [ __ ] policy you don't get
to have policy unless you elect the
people who will [ __ ] do it
so when they do something like beto did
yesterday reward them
reward them
reward them there's several different
ways to reward reward betto from
yesterday
give to his campaign
guys gotta win texas that's the only way
that greg abbott is gonna be stopped
from keep giving fellatio to the nra in
texas
and the [ __ ] policies that makes us
stack up
19 20 21 [ __ ] it doesn't matter how many
[ __ ] dead bodies are it ivaldi they
don't give a [ __ ] there could have been
400 kids killed at that school and the
republicans still would have said well
mental illness and banning backdoors
oh you can't politicize the issue oh my
god you [ __ ] a right we can
now's the time to have some [ __ ]
politics
right now
we got an election coming up
we're all one issue voters now only one
issue [ __ ] the gop [ __ ] them
and it's time to reward the politicians
that are willing to stand up and do
what's right
that policy that you want that you're
trying to run on that you're trying to
talk about all that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] line items and bills that you
want
doesn't matter what it is doesn't matter
what it is all that line item [ __ ] that
you want and bills doesn't make a hell
of beans worth of difference if you
don't elect the people that are gonna
[ __ ] do something about it and if you
think republicans are going to do
anything about the [ __ ] that you care
about you are [ __ ] out of your mind
we do have a mental illness problem in
this country if that's the case
we're gonna watch a lot of video this
morning
but some of the video from evaldi that
we're gonna show
is the good guys with guns
the cops standing outside preventing
parents from getting to their children
they were way more concerned way more
concerned preventing
parents going in because they wouldn't
we hear the parents screaming go in and
get those get that [ __ ] kill
that son of a [ __ ] he's killing our
children
nope [ __ ] them yeah now i i'm more
concerned about you staying here
we're waiting for the real good guys to
show up
there was a good guy there was an armed
guard
the back doors
didn't make a hell of beans worth the
difference
arm guard
on site
who engaged
with the shooter
the cops the cops who were there
who were trying to stop the parents from
saving their children
had [ __ ] long guns and they and flak
jackets and they were still terrified to
go in there and engage with the shooter
these cops know the equipment that
they're faced with
[ __ ] we've seen it in buffalo when the
guy with the with [ __ ] body armor
and an ar-15 style rifle went in and
killed the security guard first off
cause he was the good guy with the gun
cause really the only thing that [ __ ]
kills a good guy with a gun
is a bad guy with a gun
there's your [ __ ] logic dummy
it's a fallacy there are no good guys
there's not there's not good guys
it's just guns
it's it's just guns
those cops standing outside they just
had guns they were just dudes with guns
who didn't want to die
the lives their lives were much more
important than those children's lives in
that school
right wrong indifferent that's just a
[ __ ] simple fact
they felt that their lives were in
danger if they went in there if they
engage in fire
with someone who had who knows what kind
of weapon because how are they supposed
to know and how is lawn sport
enforcement supposed to know in texas
what kind of [ __ ] what kind of weapon
someone has
they wouldn't [ __ ] know
anyways they how the [ __ ] would they
know [ __ ] anyone can get anything
so we're going to show a heart-wrenching
video
watching parents beg
beg law enforcement
for 40 [ __ ] minutes
40 [ __ ] minutes
and i think back to the reporting that
we did live that day as the shooting was
going on
because we learned about the news when
we were live on air at the end of the
episode
on monday
or two whenever tuesday
there's so many of them you can't even
[ __ ] you don't even know what day
they're on
that's so [ __ ] pathetic
but we were live on air when the news
broke that these children were being
slaughtered
in the uvalde
elementary school rob elementary school
and the reports were that this shooter
was contained that was the words the
shooter was contained
well now we will learn that those
reports are that the shooter was able to
enter into a room lock the door behind
him and they just left him in there man
[ __ ] it yeah no big deal
let him slaughter they just kill those
people in that room you know no biggie
so let me ask you out there
if you got elementary
age children or grandchildren
what would you want
would you want law enforcement to stand
outside and wait for a more tactical
team to try to take down a gunman who's
cutting up
your your children and grandchildren
with a long rifle because the politician
said ah you can have whatever gun you
want buddy
whatever gun you want whatever gun you
want to murder children with at a school
is fine by us
because we gotta protect our tvs at our
houses
no one wants your [ __ ] tv by the way
what do you want
do you want the law enforcement to stand
outside you want the good guys to stand
outside waiting for a better team of
good guys
to help subdue
someone with a [ __ ] war machine
because the politicians
aren't working for you they're working
for the nra and the gun manufacturers
and allowing people to buy whatever
[ __ ] weapons they want whenever they
want however they want no [ __ ] big
deal
40 [ __ ] minutes
he was allowed to slaughter those people
and children in that building
and again
again
do i actually blame law enforcement
who knows what kind of [ __ ] weapon
that guy had
think about the thoughts in their brain
they know that terror in texas they're
law enforcement they certainly know the
kind of weapons that now people can get
in texas without even a guy with as long
as you're breathing and you got a
heartbeat you can get a [ __ ] gun
any gun you want
don't eat
you could you could be a crazy
[ __ ]
obvious crazy
out of your [ __ ] mind i'm talking
about mental illness ted cruz
and you can still get a gun doesn't
[ __ ] matter there's no background
check who gives a [ __ ]
you can have all kinds of [ __ ] mental
illness they keep talking about mental
illness and all this [ __ ] they don't
give a [ __ ] about mental illness they
gave a [ __ ] about mental illness they'd
make sure there was a background check
for mentally ill people not to get a
[ __ ] weapon if that was the case they
would also i don't know
be for legislation to i don't know give
[ __ ] mentally ill people health care
if you're so [ __ ] concerned about it
get off your ass and do something but
they're not and that's the point
of what betto was doing yesterday when
he was pointing at greg abbott saying do
your [ __ ] job or i'll do it
when i win [ __ ]
it's time to play politics folks
don't let them think that that's gross
oh it's gross to say that tony no it's
not
no it's [ __ ] not the only the only
way the only way to make sure your
children are safe in this country is to
[ __ ] get rid of the politicians that
are making them unsafe
the do-nothings
when it comes to their safety jesus
christ they're more worried about some
kind of [ __ ] voodoo about critical
race theory
they're worried about banning back doors
for crying out loud
they won't even give teachers the school
supplies they need to teach your
children but they want to give them a
gun
so they can kill your children and let
me explain that because i talked about
this yesterday
with my co-host gabe sanchez
what their what republicans what the gop
is asking teachers to do is kill their
students think about it
think about it put yourself
in
those [ __ ] shoes in the classroom
this shooter that went into rob
elementary knew rob elementary the
reason why is because he went there
he didn't drive from six hours away to
go to rob elementary and kill those kids
in the school he went to a school he
knew
there were teachers in that building
that taught him how to read
that taught him math
probably gave him awards
behavior awards even
they probably loved him because he was a
student and most teachers
who love to teach love their students
and you're telling me
that we're gonna make the cops the cops
who are trained outside won't even go in
but you're telling me you're gonna get a
teacher
you're gonna get a teacher
to
kill someone that they love
because the politicians made sure
that he could get a gun
with no background check
no mental health check
whatever weapons he wanted however
[ __ ] loaded he wanted to be
however big a magazine he wanted however
many magazines he wanted
you think that teacher with a pistol
is gonna is gonna be able to stop the
shooter
the armed guard on site couldn't even
stop the shooter
this is all nonsense it's all drivel
it's all distraction
from the one issue
[ __ ] the gop [ __ ] them and vote on that
because it ain't just this gun issue
it ain't just a school safety issue
they're more concerned in florida about
making sure that there's no math
and crt voodoo in math than they are
about making sure kids are safe in
schools
way more [ __ ] concerned
way more
so let's make it about politics folks
you god damn right
i will i would do just about anything
just about [ __ ] anything to make sure
that not one more kid is ripped apart by
an ar-15 in an elementary school in this
in this country not one more kid is shot
on the street not one more person shot
on the grocery tour not one more
person is slaughtered in a church
these places where you're supposed to be
safe we have the right
to life
liberty and happiness in this country
not the right to run around being
fearful
because politicians are [ __ ] cowards
like ted cruz
and greg abbott
and john cornyn and mitch mcconnell and
donald trump anyone who else who takes
money and goes speaks at an nra
convention
it's time for the politics [ __ ]
it's
time so let's make politics
out of this
politic all up and down this country
everywhere in every single corner city
councils county commissions state
legislators governor's races secretary
of state attorney generals
congressmen united states senators every
[ __ ] one of them let's make politics
out of it
you god damn right it's time to take our
[ __ ] country back from these fascists
it is time it is more than time
we i have had about enough of this
[ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ]
in this country and you should be too
and you can do something about it you
can the person who is listening to my
voice right now
you can do something
you can do a lot of things you can make
sure your family is all registered to
vote your friends your church members
your community members bach the person
who checks you out at the grocery store
i know you know cheryl
get registered donate
find those campaigns
let's do the politics things let's do
the election thing let's vote these
[ __ ] out one issue voters
[ __ ] the gop [ __ ] them
that's your issue
that's it that's the politics of it go
make it go do it
ready set go
it's time
this is the most important election and
let me tell you something after this
one's done because these fascists are
not gonna stop
they're not going to stop
there's too much money in the nra too
much money in the gun lobby too much
money in the in the pro laughers lobby
the anti-woman lobby
way
way too much money in those lobbies so
they're not gonna quit
and if you want the policy that you say
you want
then do the [ __ ] to get it
do the [ __ ] to get it
yeah it might feel a little it might
feel a little gross at first but who
gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] them
we got we got dead bodies stacking up
day after day after day after day
it's about goddamn time we the people
[ __ ] do something about this [ __ ]
so let's get it done i want to welcome
all the new listeners here i'll tell you
this is uh this has been crazy you guys
uh i did my rant yesterday midas touch
posted the rant on their youtube channel
and we've had a ton of new subscribers a
ton of new listeners i want to thank you
so much for coming
and subscribing to the channel
because we are not going to stop we are
not going to stop making politics out of
every single one of these issues
and that is what i'm going to do right
here on this show and i am going to
continue and i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] if they think we're
they're going to shame me out of it if
they think they're going to call me
names i don't give a [ __ ]
i will be your cathartic release we will
give you the messaging
we will make sure you have confidence
we have to defeat these fascist cowards
like ted cruz greg abbott mitch
mcconnell donald trump and the like of
them anyone who takes a dime
or is any kind of sycophant to the nra
is not a patriot they're unamerican
they want
the ability for people to stack up and
slaughter dead the children in schools
and churches grocery stores they want to
kill americans and that's what they're
for they are a death cult
and it's time to call them that it's
time to run on that it's time to put put
them out of our government
they can do what they want they can have
all the [ __ ] they they can talk what
they want to talk and they can have
their [ __ ] dribble
where they peddle their [ __ ] stupid
ideas and their fascism all over this
country but as long as they don't have
the [ __ ] hands their bloody hands on
our policies we're better off
we are much better off and we have to
start playing politics now right [ __ ]
now and we cannot stop
and you are part of that so thank you
for listening here on the tony michaels
podcast we air live for the new
listeners every single weekday monday
through friday two hours
two full hours
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
is the times that we air we also we also
simulcast to the midas touch facebook
page and if you've noticed there's clips
of our show that go up on the midas
touch youtube channel
and some clips we post on our channel we
also do some funny stuff political
satire some parody you know to keep you
laughing
you know we have the cathartic release
here but you also
have to be entertained to some degree
you gotta you gotta laugh at some point
even though some of this stuff is
depressing as [ __ ]
sad as hell and some of the stuff we're
gonna watch today
is gut wrenching
but you must know this stuff you must
know what is happening we can not we
cannot look away
at what they want and what they're doing
they have deluded a part of america
deluded them
there's an unfortunate picture out there
of i think a father of one of the
victims
and yevaldi
and then they post a picture of and said
why on a social media post
and the shirt that he's wearing
while he's taking the picture
of the poor little girl who was
mowed down
by weapons that greg abbott allowed this
18 year old to get
on his shirt it says [ __ ] your gun-free
zone
all but promoting
the slaughter
there are no good guys
there's no good guys
it's just guns
just guns
and we need to make politics out of it
and we need to not we need to not stop
making politics out of it we can't quit
even if we get the policy that we want
even if eventually we can almost all but
eradicate gun violence we can not stop
we can't stop
they're not going to they'll be back
if we change the policies if you get all
the line item bills that you want
they're still not going to stop so we
can't
we have to keep going
one issue voters one issue
[ __ ]
the g.o.p
[ __ ] them we will be right back after
this break don't go anywhere we'll see
you on the other side
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
dearest tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
lead loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
again i want to welcome all the new
listeners out there boy do we have new
listeners
holy moly
join us every single week day monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific live
live for two hours on youtube twitter
and twitch and simo casting from the
midas touch facebook page
also download gabe have you seen the
downloads holy [ __ ] they're looking good
oh my god they're looking good go
download every single episode of the
tony michaels podcast
on apple spotify and google and all your
favorite directories they're out there
they're out there folks and i know they
are because you are downloading the [ __ ]
out of these episodes so thank you very
much uh to keep tuning in
keep sending the great comments we've
had some great comments on the
youtube here lately um and and and the
chat is fantastic whether you're on
facebook twitch
twitter
youtube of course on youtube you can
come
get in on the super chat now i know
the last couple days we had some
problems with the super chat or
something and we're still trying to get
it fixed i got part of it fixed i don't
know i was like we're back we're back we
are back but it's it's weird youtube has
i don't know
i don't know it takes it thank you
you've seen it it takes a big tech baby
just trying to suppress i know but you
know that's what it is it's the deep
state i mean that's what i think it is
right i don't i don't know i don't i
don't know i don't know if
might be george soros his check bounced
or something yeah yeah maybe you know i
get those checks and i go
deposit them but you know i haven't
gotten my check in a little bit so oh
yeah maybe i don't know maybe it might
be like did you renew your antifa
membership you got to renew it every
single year to get that check oh you
know what yeah okay hold on i've got
some
yeah
did you miss it in the mail did you miss
it in the mail just they mailed out new
antique of a membership card got it okay
okay yeah all right yeah well
i've got a pile of papers here so i'm
sure i can i'll figure it out by today
okay good good well good good good i'm
i'm happy that you'll you'll work on
your antifa membership
so did you see the some of these clips
because ted cruz is a coward is our
title today and you did a wonderful job
yesterday um
the youtube thumbnail is beautiful it's
one of the best thumbnails that you've
ever thank you yeah well i couldn't have
done it without ted cruz well that is
true and then today today we course ted
cruz makes a fool out of himself and
several clips and one with sky news and
i know what other interviews he's
talking about back doors and [ __ ]
yeah this is the guy who's trying to ban
dildos at one point and he wants to he
thinks the solution you know
honestly
it makes a lot of sense you know when
you're trying to plug up one hole you
know the other one opens up and then
here are you guys those are the back
doors i'm talking about the doors oh
okay but you know yeah or or you know
the dildos too
but yeah uh
it
i mean yeah he's a he is a is a ted cruz
uh tried to ban dildos ted cruz can't
even defend his wife you know he's like
listen heidi okay it's it's not like i
agreed with them you know i just didn't
say anything right
uh and it's like no no i don't i don't i
don't feel insecure you know i'm not
trying to ban dildos because i've got
some sort of like inferiority complex or
something why would you why would you
suggest that huh
well here's the uh let me see if i can
pull up this is the sky news
have you just watched this clip yet yeah
yeah okay so you did watch it um this is
a sky news now i'm going to show you
another one with the back doors but this
is the one that's really it's got i
don't know this this post has got two
million
um views on it i think
and uh this is this is uh senator cancun
cruz now remember this is the guy
you know he hates the truth and he's
offended
um
and he's he he keeps he keeps saying
some things here
well let's just watch and you'll
understand what i'm talking about there
are 19 sets of parents
who who are never going to get to kiss
their child tonight because of greg
abbott and you
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know
well you know politics
it's easy to go into politics
because you're a pilot you know what you
know what this this is [ __ ] nonsense
where we can't make politics out of this
and we're like oh we're not making pop
we are going to make we are going to
make politics out of this that's what
democrats should be saying like right
now that's what beto said yesterday do
your [ __ ] job they are politicians
yes the [ __ ] root word of politician
is politics right and you've got you've
got ted cruz you got greg abbott and the
rest of his goons you got whoever that
got one guy isn't a walker who's like
you should have apparently that was the
mayor of uvalde
and that's all right i'm sure that guy's
on fox news a bunch i don't know i don't
right so i i don't want to go too big
into him yet because i'm sure we're
gonna we're gonna do that in a second
but right
um yeah 100 you know like fully support
somebody confronting politicians to say
hey you're [ __ ] failing at doing your
job and you're not representing us the
citizens the constituents who put you in
office just because you've got your
position doesn't mean you can exploit us
and take money from the nra and you know
then you want to on the flip side say oh
well 19 parents are or 19 babies aren't
going to be able to kiss their parents
and say good night to their parents and
this and this and that well here's the
thing buddy you can't just then say that
and then when asked what will you do
about it i mean it's as bad as mansion
being like i will do anything i can to
stop this from happening and like okay
great will you uh just abolish the
filibuster well
guys i mean i said anything but i didn't
mean anything right right i meant
nothing i meant right and ted cruz is
the same way they're like okay this
seems like a pretty
pretty big travesty this is the second
uh biggest
or the second largest american school
shooting next to sandy hook right you
look at that and you say
maybe this is a time to
to to change things up right we went 10
years we didn't really do anything and
now the second event happens how long
until another one and another one and
another one and then they're like listen
this is a good time for gun reform right
and he goes yeah well okay guys
what do you no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
you know he keeps talking about the 19
parents here right i bet the 19 sets of
parents and now it's like 20 or 21
something you know it could be a hundred
and they still wouldn't give a [ __ ]
right like it could be 150 sets of
parents and and ted cruz wouldn't give a
[ __ ]
i bet
if you go ask those 19 sets of parents
almost every one of them and when you
ask when when is the time for politics
and gun reform they would have said
oh last week
last week
before
my kids were killed like that was the
time probably for the politics
and the gun reform that's probably when
we should like last year or the year
before that really 20 years ago when the
[ __ ] assault weapons ban uh was let
to expire during a republican
administration in a republican congress
when that that's probably that's
probably would have been the time to
play politics so democrats out there
that are scared to play politics you you
people are not paying attention play
politics with this everywhere you can
anywhere you can play the politics like
beto did yesterday let's finish what
coward cruz has to say here
it's important it's at the heart of the
issue i i get that that's where the
media likes to go it's not it's where
many of the people we've talked to here
like to go yeah proposals from democrats
in the media i love that too how it's
democrats in the media like
i mean you're
they always they want to make the media
the democrats and the democrats like we
ate the [ __ ] media too like the only
reason why i like this interview this
sky news because sky news isn't american
media and he doesn't take no [ __ ] here
from ted cruz yeah and he goes he
doesn't both sides he doesn't take and
this is the reason why ted cruz gets
pissed off here is because this guy
keeps challenging him even though ted
cruz just keeps spewing up the same old
[ __ ] dribble listen
inevitably when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two
ar-15s if you want to stop
violent crime
and the rules the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this why does
this only happen in your country i
really think that's what many people
around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect
you get your political agenda no it's us
god love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why i love that as
soon as he challenges him with the
american exceptionalism where ted cruz
ted cruz actually has to explain what
what he believes american exceptionalism
is as soon as he has to [ __ ] put
words to american exceptionalism he
[ __ ] runs away because gabe he can't
do it the the thing that i see
that i that i like kind of got through
here was when he goes i'm sorry you've
you don't
what do you say i'm sorry you don't like
american exceptionalism right right
that's like he he decides to take that
moment to say everything that he just
brought up he goes well i'm sorry you
feel that way that's the same way and i
know
people really have pet peeves about that
and it really is dismissive and
gaslighting in the sense that like when
you say
hey uh i'm upset about
xyz and somebody goes i'm sorry you feel
that way
which is totally dismissive to not even
say like oh [ __ ] okay uh i'm not
listening to this person i know i've
done that before and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
should not do that when somebody brings
something up i'm like oh i'm sorry you
feel that way or like i'm sorry you feel
that way and it's like
that's that's not that's not a great
response because what you just did right
there was you said you feel a certain
way and that's the only thing you feel
and that's your thing and i really won't
do anything about it and i'm not going
to have any sort of empathy for you i'm
just gonna say it is what it is and
unfortunately
that's how you feel
right and so when i hear something like
this which is like he's like listen it's
not just the media it's everyone
everyone [ __ ] feels this way everyone
doesn't want to have
dead children and and just slaughtered
in a classroom
and then ted cruz goes well you know
look it's a i'm sorry you hate american
exceptionalism like
right oh how you're talking about how
exceptional what happened in
elementary school oh how exceptional is
that
let's finish because
this this reporter
does what american reporters don't
generally do right and he he doesn't
give a [ __ ] if ted cruz is running or
not he's not going to stop here you do
not think that guns are the problem why
is this just an american problem
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
mass shooting but you can't answer that
you can't answer that can you say you
can't answer that why is this why is it
that people come from all over the world
to america because it's the freest most
prosperous safest country
and it may be the freestyle maybe the
most why are our kids
total projection there and i love i love
how it's the freest safest greatest
place on earth but as soon as there's a
[ __ ] snow storm in texas he goes to
mexico right
this is the guy this guy's saying that
oh the reason why there's so many people
come to this country because it's the
freest and safest the most beautiful and
god bless america and blah blah blah on
the flag and put my hand on my heart and
all this [ __ ] but as soon as as soon as
soon
as ted cruz may not have electric in his
home because there's a snowstorm in
texas because republicans have [ __ ]
destroyed any chance that texans would
have a [ __ ] power grid during a
snowstorm
he buys a plane ticket to another
country on a beach not only that but
he goes to cancun then when he gets
busted blames his daughters and then you
find out that he abandoned his dog which
is ironically named snowflake wow i mean
you can't make this [ __ ] and then then
he comes back and he takes a video of
him putting a couple cases of water in
cars he's like everything's good now
yeah everything's good now just like
yesterday this theater
you've seen this theater with the with
the the nra presser that we played live
right you know we had this nra presser
that was live it it featured um
the coward greg abbott and did just as
much of a coward
uh of dan patrick
and ted cruz was there too and beto you
know he
he crashed it he crashed their party now
this is this is hilarious
um this is a gary has this here
never forget this moment this is a great
great meme everyone needs to spread this
around let me
see if i can take the i want everyone to
see let me take the
banner down here
it says
when you order thoughts and prayers but
do your [ __ ] job shows up
like look at look at him
look at him and beto's just like [ __ ]
you i am gonna stand here and i am gonna
tell you exactly how i feel
now we didn't we actually
watched this live and we posted a video
um after the fact
that uh well our clip
our clip of that part of the show where
we were playing the the nra presser from
greg abbott live um
but we didn't play the
the video
outside the the high school is where
this was being held the high school
auditorium right um which is something i
want to play because i think that's
important if i can find it here
um
as we go through talking about when he
goes outside and yeah yeah well there's
several there's several there's several
videos
from outside because he keeps going
better does not stop like he's not just
gonna let the
them kicking him out of an auditorium uh
frustrate him to that point here is um
here's one of the videos from outside
the high school auditorium here of beto
o'rourke 50th in the nation in mental
health care access 50th there are only
50 states in the nation we are dead last
the number one provider of mental health
care services under greg abbott in the
state of texas is the county jail system
in the state of texas the largest
inpatient mental health care facility in
the state of texas is the harris county
jail in downtown houston texas he's
refused to expand medicaid which would
bring 10 billion dollars a year
including mental health care access
having trouble they may kill somebody
that may kill themselves a red flag law
would protect the public he's refused
he's refused he's refused he's refused
to support safe storage laws so young
people cannot get their hands on their
parents guns
he's refused he's refused to support
he's refused to support a ban on ar-15s
and ak-47s this 18-year-old who just
turned 18 bought an ar-15 and took it
into an elementary school and shot kids
in the face and killed them why are we
letting this happen in this country why
is this happening in this state year
after year city after city this is on
all of us if we do not do something and
i am going to do something i'm not alone
the people of texas are with us the
majority of the people of texas are with
us but we've got to stand up to this or
we just accept this theater and business
as usual and we accept the next shooting
we could have stopped this if we had
stood up after santa fe high school if
we had stood up after el paso we are
going to stop the next one we're
standing up right here in uvalde texas
right now that's why i'm here so the
people of texas want right now that's
what we're going to focus on 50th in the
so beto there
really really showing the democrats
nationally what the [ __ ] to do like this
is the model this is the model don't
don't play the [ __ ] [ __ ] theater
[ __ ] that [ __ ] theater the business
is usual theater [ __ ] them [ __ ] them you
be one issue voters one issue voters is
[ __ ] the gop they're not doing a goddamn
thing let's vote them the [ __ ] out oh
mental illness mental illness is the
problem they're not doing a goddamn
thing right not a goddamn thing not a
god damn thing back doors are the
problem uh you think you think you think
any [ __ ] republican in texas is gonna
legislate anything about a backdoor not
a goddamn one of them not a god even if
that was the problem ted cruz even if
that was the problem they wouldn't
legislate it
they wouldn't because it doesn't it
doesn't give any more money to the gun
manufacturer right i mean i look at that
i look at the suggestions that ted cruz
has made right and he says yesterday
which i'm sure we'll play a clip in a
second which is him saying oh listen
listen i figured out the problem the
problem and i've consulted with other
people who are who are victims and other
and other experts and they say the
answer
to eliminating this type of event from
happening again
is only having one door okay okay fine
ted cruz let's assume you could do one
door all right yeah let's ignore the
fire marshal that says that's just a
code that's just breaking a code right
there let's just let's just
ignore that uh that there wouldn't be a
fire right and that people would be
trapped inside and there was only one
way to get out thousands of kids or
hundreds of kids and let's assume that
yes okay there was one door
you created an incident
and that the shooter wasn't outside just
picking off kids
like yeah let's make it super easy for
people to just die put their lives at
risk or just utterly break any sort of
sense of
of of of logic or or or anything like
you
ted cruz once again shows us that you do
not have to be smart to go to princeton
you do not have to be smart to go to
harvard law
you do not have to be smart to be a
politician
ted cruz
is the epitome
of dumb
[ __ ] cowards
[Music]
absolutely well here's here's that
jewish gender resistor has uh a post
here of the video that i want to show
says
but the commentary is spot on here can
you imagine if ted cruz stood up to guns
the way he does back doors
it's not even mental health anymore it's
back doors i guess the back door
lobbyists miss their payment because
we know the nra hasn't
so um they're assuming that
the back door lobby has not paid ted
cruz so that's why ted cruz is going
after the back doors which is not a bad
not a bad idea right not a bad idea and
so let's listen in to what ted cruz says
about back doors do you want to talk
about how we could have prevented the
horror that played out across the street
yeah let's hear it ted let's hear let's
hear how you expect to make sure that a
psychopath as you put it doesn't get a
[ __ ] gun that can murder children
let's hear it buddy look the killer
entered here the same way the killer
entered santa fe
through a back door an unlocked back
door
i sat down at round tables with the
families from santa fe we talked about
what we need to do to harden schools
including not having unlocked
back doors including not having unlocked
doors to classroom having one door that
goes in and out of the school having
armed police officers at that one door
so here here is the thing this did not
age well at [ __ ] all and the reason
why i didn't age well is because we're
finding reports that the good guys the
armed guards with the guns weren't
letting parents in and they had they had
made sure that the shooter had locked
himself in a room with people right
shooting them murdering them like
literally it's the exact opposite of
what ted cruz is saying here the exact
opposite it's yeah it it honestly like
it's not only this but it's also the
thing yesterday which was like okay
good guy one good guy with the good with
a gun
one good guy with a gun versus a bad guy
with the gun
well sorry but that good guy with the
gun was killed outside right so he got
inside the the guy
like just killed him went through went
into the school locked himself in
got into the classroom
what good is it there right
was it actually the back door was it
like i mean like here's the thing it
doesn't matter what side of the building
it was it doesn't matter the front the
back the top of the [ __ ] roof
the point is
the kid came in
with more than one gun
he was able to legally obtain
said guns
and use them to kill people
and ted cruz wants to say uh it's not
mental health
it's not the fact that he anyone could
buy a gun you know permales carry
it's not the fact that
we should have done a better job about
this the the problem really
is the door right it well i mean not
only the door itself gabe we have to ban
right that's totally bad
like okay in in ted cruz is reality
right let's put ourselves out i don't
want to go ditch it grace's reality i'm
not going to go i'm not going to go too
far deep into that okay well it's not
it's a kind of a shallow reality
let's just keep it surface level we'll
do a thought experiment here good ted
cruz says he wants to only have one door
right right she's like okay okay well
let's not make it easy for guns to get
into the door
what he is suggesting is essentially
creating
a doggy door flap
that's what he wants he wants okay
here's the door for some bigger items
that could come through like let's say
we're moving some furniture in during
the school year or something or we got
to move stuff out at the end for summer
but then he's like all right if kids
need to get in
they need to go through the doggy crawl
right right they gotta crawl through
first you gotta take off your backpack
cause your backpack's gonna get stuck
but
that was the bulletproof backpack that
you had so you gotta take that off
unprotected crawl through
hand the backpack through
and then now that you're inside yeah
you're trapped but
the guy with the gun can't get in right
right i mean that's that's how dumb this
sounds
it's how dumb this [ __ ] is a lot of
[ __ ] that ted cruz says sounds really
dumb because that video that video is
not the only time there was a fox news
interview and i was like oh he doubled
down on this idea he
just can't stop with the back door stuff
i don't know if he's still focused on
the dildo band and the back door he's
getting confused i don't know but here's
the thing here's the thing that i know
in my experience
with school buildings so when i was in
high school many years ago and it was
many years ago
it was it was i'm coming up on 20 years
gabe
now yeah wow so here's the thing
there was a the high school that i went
to
they built a new addition they built a
new library new cafeteria right
now when they added this onto the school
it was it was in the it was in the
really late 90s when they passed this
legislation and really started the
project
in the late 90s there was an assault
weapon band right
when they were when they were planning
out the [ __ ] school the addition to
the school for the cafeteria and the
the new principal's office the new front
office and the new library and all that
[ __ ]
they did not take into account assault
weapons because they were banned there
was no there was no uh atrium where you
were to make sure that no gunman could
get in there was multiple entrances into
this into this new addition
i i mean
there was no no reason to believe that
you would have to build a school with
assault weapons now let's fast forward a
little bit
my daughter goes to an elementary school
that is an older building
recently in the last few years they took
the handles off all the doors on the
outside of the building it's like
besides the front door
and there's one back door that stays
locked permanently that still has a hand
on it but it stays locked from the
outside you cannot get into it only
certain times a day do they unlock it
right that's their policy so it is
unlocked sometimes
because of the structure of the school
and where
parents pick these kids up and where the
after-school care is and that sort of
thing
now
what they did do is they spend all kinds
of money at this school to build a
special entrance
to make sure that a gunman can't get
into that school
they built a whole interest to make sure
not a person
a gun they built a whole entrance to
make sure a gun can't get past that
entrance there's a [ __ ] button that
they push to lock those doors if someone
comes in that atrium
they lock the [ __ ] doors
with a button the secretary now he she's
she or he is probably going to be shot
almost immediately because there's a
little window there
now i don't know if it's bull proof
class or whatever maybe they went to
that extent but literally we are
building entrances to schools rebuilding
them to make sure that a gun doesn't go
past a certain point and we're like oh
it's it's bad guys it's not it's not bad
guys it's the [ __ ] gun yeah it's
always been
a gun it's just a [ __ ] gun now
fast forward just a little bit forward
further
they built a brand new high school in
our town brand new high school my son
goes to that high school
the people who built that high school
the company that built that high school
game builds prisons
oh yeah they build prisons
and now they're in the now they're in
the high school building business
because we literally have to build
schools
in the event that a gun would get past a
certain point in that school and what
better people to make sure
that the people are locked in to that
school than
than than a company that builds prisons
we're crying out loud are you listening
to what i'm saying folks
we are hiring
companies that build prisons to build
our schools
because
of a gun
right and everyone's like it's not the
gun it's mental illness it's not gun
it's this it's not the gun it's that
it's not it's the [ __ ] gun
they are building buildings where
children are learning
and they they intentionally build these
buildings in a certain way
because of a gun
not anything else a gun right
you people have lost your [ __ ] minds
if you don't think we should make
politics out of this the
uh before we go there is one thing um
people are saying there's a walkout
which we can go to and i think it's uh i
think they were saying at noon which
if that's noon eastern it happened when
we came live i haven't seen um yeah i
haven't seen parts of it if you can find
it i'm gonna while you're looking for
that i want to bring up
speaking of good guys bad guys and
getting into schools and doors and all
this [ __ ] all this [ __ ] nonsense
let me show you the reality of what
happened
at uvalde with the supposed good guys
with the guns now
from my understanding from the reporting
because it's very been very conflicting
we've had different reports at different
periods and different reports are
changing some of them are changing back
it's very hard to understand what
happened and we probably won't know for
several days maybe weeks of exactly what
happened on the ground there i wouldn't
be surprised if the police and you've uh
ivaldi are going to continue to change
their story absolutely which is going to
change this whole
you know because they're like oh you
know
the cop was doing this or this what are
you doing this or whatever and this is
where the guy gets no we're going to
find out more and more that it was
actually incompetence
lack of preparation
and totally dismisses this fantasy world
of good guy with a gun right it well
it's all it's all a fallacy it always
has been but here's but here's some of
the reports
so the first report was is that they had
the shooter contained and you remember
when we were live on there that's what
they said right but apparently what had
happened was as he had locked himself in
a room and it happened a couple
different times and they did not pursue
him into that room and there's several
videos out there i'm gonna show this one
here but there's several videos out
there a parent trying to tell these
police officers get your ass in that
school
and handle this [ __ ] situation with
this gun so it doesn't kill our children
right and it appears
through the reporting that they were
waiting on the border patrol tactical
team so there's a tactical team on the
ground now the other really weird
suspicious report is a report that an
off-duty border patrol officer
went in with another tactical with a
different tactical team than the one
they were waiting for to go in and to
subdue
this shooter
they are even passing around uh
photos of a hat that was shot off his
head or something like that and even so
i'm not sure
exactly all this
where all this is coming from and what
the reports are and the timing of it but
let me play you this video
because this is from outside the school
these parents are begging these police
officers to go in and they're telling
the police officers if you won't go in
i'm gonna go in and try to save my
children which i don't blame them but
let's watch it's hard to watch folks but
we cannot look away we have to know the
reality of what is happening when these
school shootings happen and this fallacy
of good guy with the gun [ __ ] it is
just guns and i'm not blaming the police
officers here gabe they're trying to
make sure they don't die
right because of this gun because how
the hell are they supposed to know in
texas with the laws that they don't have
what kind of gun or how many guns this
guy's got
right so they're waiting for a tactical
team because let's face it most police
officers they don't have enough [ __ ]
training they don't have the money for
it everyone says oh democrats say defund
the police the only ones that have
defunded the police are republicans
republicans in control have defunded the
police so much so that these guys are
terrified to go in that [ __ ] school
yeah and engage with the shooter watch
[Applause]
now what it appears to be here as a
police officer is put someone on the
ground if you look in between the cars
here they got someone right there see
him got him on the ground there gabe
in between the cars it appears this
person was like no i'm gonna go in um
and then of course everyone's yelling it
is a hysterical moment
all because greg abbott had to make sure
that anyone could get a gun at any
moment at any time and any gun they
wanted without a background check
without as long as you got a heartbeat
and you're breathing [ __ ] you can
have a gun that's the reason why we have
this hysteria in this video let's watch
you see the officer here
now
the bad guy with the gun game the bad
guy with the gun is on the inside of the
school and he's murdering teachers staff
and children
now this police officer has his taser
out right yeah so at least he didn't
mistake it for a gun you know well right
well this this officer right here is the
good guy with the gun this is by the
republicans [ __ ] [ __ ] argument
right this is the good guy with a gun he
has a taser out to tase the parents of
the children that are being killed on
the inside where the bad guy is
think about that for a second
think about this for a second this
officer is standing there with a taser
prepared to tase the parents of the
children that are being killed by the
[ __ ] bad guy
and this is supposed to be the good guy
with the gun right okay this is the
situation that republicans have created
in texas by defunding the police
by probably making sure that police not
only are not trained but they're not
qualified to be police officers and law
enforcement in the first place but we
also have gun laws where these guys are
terrified because they don't know what
kind of guns that shooter could or could
not have let's watch
don't look away you cannot look away
now ted cruz says he wants armed guards
at elementary schools which makes sense
considering that you've got people who
are building schools are the people who
are also building prisons so it's like
why not make the teachers the prison
guards right well exactly but here we
have arm guards
right we have armed guards
these armed guards by the way are from
multiple different agencies right some
are sharing not just cops right yeah
you've got border patrol and other you
got a swat team coming in you got all
the sheriff
multiple people
who are armed and supposedly trained in
any given situation
to prevent this or at least
work to to stop a further
uh escalation
in this event
and they're out here think about this
though
ted cruz says what we need to prevent
bad guys from getting in schools right
is armed guards
and one door now these parents are
trying to get in a door to go get their
children and armed guards are preventing
them from getting in the school
right literally what ted cruz is saying
is what is happening in this video but
it's not good guy bad guy [ __ ] stop
doing that stuff stop playing that game
there is no good guys there is no bad
guys
all the all the guys with the guns all
the guys with the guns all of them they
got a gun and some of them
think they're the bad guy or think
they're the good guy and they're
actually the bad guys stop that nonsense
there is no good guys bad guys because
if there is good guys the good guys here
are stopping the bad guys to get in the
school the the bad guys are the parents
of the children being slaughtered inside
the building by the person with the
weapon
think about this for a second think
about our culture and where we've come
to at this [ __ ] point
and and the thing is we have now have
video of this
because we now everyone has a goddamn
camera on their cell phone we don't have
this kind this much footage from sandy
hook gabe did you know sandy hook has
been 10 years yeah
10 years
it's two years today that george floyd
was killed was murdered by a cop a good
guy with a gun
derek chauvin
but it's been 10 years since sandy hook
10 [ __ ] years
and this is why this type of footage is
new to us this is why it's new to us
is because it's ten years later folks
you gotta pluck your head out of your
ass and understand this is all politics
all of it is so make it politics we have
to elect people who are going to fix the
problem that you see right in front of
your face and don't look away at the
problem in front of your face or you may
make a bad decision on electing an
official let's watch
to prevent people from going into school
you're watching
[Music]
i just want to point out there's like a
one two three four five officers
standing here uh in tactical gear and
and they've got these long guns here
just hanging out man just hanging out
well you know they're hoping that
honestly
honestly i think these people who are
who are uh who have shown up and armed
military outfits just flak jackets and
guns assault rifles handguns tasers a
helmet
all of these guys they don't want to be
there
they do not want to be there
for many reasons one this is a true this
is a travesty of an event two
they
probably don't want to actually shoot
someone like that is the lowest thing on
the [ __ ] totem pole when you enter
law enforcement you're not joining and
if you are then obviously you know
hopefully you get screened out when
you're going through the uh the training
process
but nobody walks into their job every
day going i hope to god some guy pulls
his gun out so i can [ __ ] blast him
to the curb that is not what a person
who is in law enforcement should be
thinking
as the default
they should not have that thought so not
only do these people not want to be
there
but they're also like [ __ ] i'm not going
in that building
in their mind they're probably thinking
i really hope this situation resolves
itself like i don't want to have to be
the guy that goes in and gets shot i
don't have to be the guy that goes in
and has to kill this person
the other thing too is like when you're
uh when you're in law enforcement and
you fire
your firearm you shoot your gun at
someone or or or wherever
you have to go through counseling
right because that's a dramatic event
shooting someone potentially killing
someone
like if you just ignore that go okay
yeah just get right back on the street
and go do your beat like
that is
one
incredibly
incredibly unprofessional but two when
somebody does that when they shoot when
they fire their their gun
they have to sit down and be like okay
so what happened let's talk about it why
did you decide that was the only action
you could take
because that's a serious [ __ ] action
that is a big decision to make
and i bet none of these guys want to be
there none of these guys want to have to
go into the school and kill this person
well and they don't want to be shot at
themselves exactly
and who's going to blame them and i said
it yesterday like we live in a country
where it has become the default
that we just assign responsibility that
some random person a good guy with a gun
or not
should be the person that has to risk
their life
to save another person's nobody wakes up
in the morning and says today
i'm gonna jump in front of another
person nobody wants to do that nobody
even wants to conceive the idea that
they have to be the one that risks their
life there's you know today i might die
but at least i save someone else like
how how messed up is that idea that
that's the that's the that is the
ideology that republicans and ray have
put in in our minds in this country
that's the culture we live in let's
finish watching this because i have a
video uh speaking of the walkouts from a
mission school in michigan where they're
doing a walk out i want to play that too
so let's play this uh finish this up
video and then we'll move to the
walkouts because a few more videos that
i want to show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the anguish of these parents and his
family members
and the arm guards holding them back
from the school because the arm guards
won't go into the school i want to go to
this video here um
and i don't mean to switch gears so fast
but
i've got some other video i want to show
here so i want to show this video here
um i believe mj or kalyn sent it here
i'm not sure which um but here is this
is in the uh michigan school it's oxford
high school they staged a walkout and
they're creating a u on the football
field here now recount has this on their
page and i'll retweet it here so you
guys can go find the video and the post
but the
apparently this again this is oxford
high school in michigan
um uh yeah lord students were killed
here uh several others injured last
november um i i don't know which
see here's the problem here gabe is i
don't know which school shooting this is
but this high school i don't know if
it's the one where the parents ran off
to canada and left the kid i'm not sure
if that's the one or not uh but this is
oxford high school in michigan where
there was a shooting last november so
not that long ago where four students
were killed
and they are um they're doing a walkout
um
to um honor the victims
at uvalde by forming a u on the football
field and apparently there's a lot of
walkouts all over the country um that
we're seeing so
um
so this is that is ethan crumbly he is
the one from oxford that uh
yeah it's the parents it's the parents
because it's the parents that were like
oh
and i believe they're charging the
parents in in yeah yeah
i mean he's charged with 24 counts
including four counts of murder and a
terrorism charge right um
let's see i had some more video that i
wanted to show you guys today because
it's just it's never ending here's a
here's a great video from
um the great shannon watts
um
from mom's demand action and you know
they're they're a group that that
absolutely
lean lean into
gun reform um
shannon does nothing but volunteer her
time to try to to try to push forward
the politics of gun reform which i
applaud her for and we need we need more
like shannon and i think we continue she
even says it in the video that
um their group is growing because more
and more
more and more parents
children are being killed in schools
this is so ridiculous that we're going
to get to a point where the coalition is
so big because so many parents have had
their [ __ ] children killed in schools
this is ridiculous that we have to
continue to do this but let's listen to
shannon here this is very important
stuff
we are begging
begging our elected officials to do
something
anything
to address america's gun violence crisis
they
have enabled this
they are enabling gun violence with
their inaction
we know how to stop this
we know how to keep people safe while
they're grocery shopping
while they're in school
while they're worshiping
so we ask our senators who do you work
for
[Applause]
the nra that's right you [ __ ] work
for the 90 of americans who support
common sense gun safety laws
or do you work for gun manufacturers who
pad your pockets and protect your power
while over 110 americans are shot and
killed every day
take a look at the sea of red shirts
we are growing stronger every day
and we are not going anywhere
[Applause]
if i've learned anything from the
courageous gun violence survivors who
show up and do this work every single
day it's this
we will win this fight
because parents fighting to keep their
kids safe will always
out organize
at work
and outvote gun lobby executives
fighting for their prophets
we will never
give up
thank you shannon
and you shouldn't give up either uh you
should take uh i mean that is the that
is the uh last person you want to piss
off a mother right a mother who has lost
their child
due to being murdered by a gun
that was
legally purchased especially
due to laws that our lawmakers put in
place republicans
that is the last person that you want to
[ __ ] piss off
well i tell you what they pissed women
off in this country they want to take
away their rights they want to take away
their liberty and now they want to they
now they want to tell them that their
kids can't be safe in schools um unless
they're law enforcement because right
right but here's the here's the thing
you make you bring up a good point that
i just want to
now i'm going to blow some people's
minds here kind of crazy
here's the thing concealed carry laws do
not significantly reduce homicides or
any other violent crimes okay placing
armed guards like the good guys with the
guns that everyone keeps advocating for
like ted cruz and ken paxton and all
these other dumb [ __ ] here's the thing
putting armed guards in schools
do not protect people from mass
shootings in fact
putting armed guards according to a
study putting armed guards in a school
actually increases the [ __ ]
likelihood that there is a higher death
toll during a mass shooting
and not only
does it make the situation worse you
also create an environment of fear
you're governing children by fear you're
doing the same thing
that an armed guard at a prison does
i've got a gun
you are totally helpless
i've got the power
you're ruled by my fear in the gun
that's on my hip
whether i'm properly trained or not
properly trained in any given situation
the guy who is armed is probably most
likely most definitely going to make the
situation even worse
like that's the fact like that's that's
just the the fact of the matter those
are the studies that have come out the
research that has been done
anyone wants to say oh it's not the gun
it's the person behind the gun
it's the gun it's the gun it's the gun
it's always been the gun if you want to
always be the [ __ ] gun even law
enforcement no it's a gun uh mind is
margie has sent me this uh clip here
um this is an interview done and it
looks like a law enforcement officer
texas dps
uh is giving a um
an interview here let's listen to what
this says and we've also uh heard word
that border patrol agent was struck with
gunfire a few officers shot we've heard
that some law enforcement officers
actually went into school
to get their kids out can you talk about
that
did you hear what she just said
the law enforcement officials
went in to get their
children out
now we just watched a video here just a
minute ago where law enforcement was
blocking parents from going into school
to get their children the law
enforcement are going into the school to
retreat retrieve law enforcement's
children
the more the more with this the more
this news leaks out and the more you
start to put this together this looks
just absolutely oh yeah bonkers so
you're telling me that the good guy with
the gun
acted selfishly
to to get his own kids out he said [ __ ]
the other kids i'm going after my kid
well yeah well i mean gabe again again
again and again and again i say there is
no good guy it's only a gun only a gun
that is it
let's listen to what jesus i can't even
believe
we're even here in this place but let's
listen right so we do know vanessa right
now that there was some uh police
officers families trying to get their
children out of school because it was an
active shooter situation right now it's
a terrible situation right now and of
course just as we mentioned the loss of
life it's it's just terrible it's a
terrible tragedy when it took place but
again we've got to remember those brave
men and women that actually were there
on scene
that met the suspect and of course
we know that they were they met him did
they shake his hand did they go buy him
burger king
yeah great uh can i get my kids and then
you can you can you can do whatever you
want to i mean honestly it's like
they're putting in an order they're like
hey so listen i'm gonna go pick up my
kids from the shooter and save them
anybody else want anything you guys good
you guys good okay i'm gonna go head out
i'll be right back right
like this is crazy i can't even believe
that this person is saying these things
or some of them were shot but at the end
of this the suspect was shot is now
deceased the threat is now neutralized
oh well thank thank goodness you got
your children out thank goodness
the thing you know there's this person
that's in the comments and it this
person is giving gabe a bad name okay
uh we share the same name and i feel
sorry for them what i would like to say
is that this person that's in the
comments right now is talking about how
a gun it's the gun the gun's an
inanimate object well here's the thing
buddy if we increase the volume of guns
that are available and accessible on the
street
we already know from research and
studies that it shows that increasing
the amount of guns makes the situation
worse
wait wait wait you mean
you mean you're telling me that when
there's gun violence more guns that are
included in that violence is worse is
that what you're saying we have more
guns and i said yesterday we have we
have over
393 million guns in this country we have
331 million people in this country the
guns outnumber the people
okay there are there is a direct
correlation between the number of guns
we have in america and the number of gun
related debts that we have in america
okay that is indisputable that is just
for straight fact i'm sorry you know
facts over feelings here but that's how
it goes
so when somebody comes in and says oh
the gun's an inanimate object
well here's the thing maybe if there
were less guns there'd be less of these
crimes because what we've also found is
that increasing the amount of guns on
the street
and concealed carry
actually makes it worse
because you got a random bunch of people
who decided hey i'm of age i'm going
gonna legally purchase this gun and i'm
gonna put it on my hip and whether i
have to tell you or not and maybe i
don't even have to have a permit
especially in texas let's see how that
goes let's just throw a bunch of [ __ ] at
the wall and see what sticks
like the idea that all of a sudden
all of a sudden
more guns are gonna make the situation
go down like
with a bunch of people in a gun or just
like automatically a deterrent no
you got other variables that go into
place some guy says i'm macho
it is you're real gabe and apparently
the other one is not gabe it's thank you
gabe thank you um so i want to move to
uh to
switch gears here for a second but i
want to show the audience
why it is so important uh to make
politics out of this oh boy here is this
bonehead herschel walker he he i he i'm
i'm almost excited gabe after after you
watch this video you'll understand what
i'm talking about yeah don't worry he's
on my list
yeah yeah yeah to do a video of what was
that so hershel walker um i'm almost
after this video i'm almost really
excited because this is the best that
they have in georgia um this person this
guy also won the primary by not showing
up to the debates
he was a ghost he literally was not
there he doesn't even live in georgia
yes
he lives in texas and i love how i love
how it says atlanta here on fox news you
know that's a [ __ ] lie right no way
is he in atlanta he's not we're coming
in live from texas right right right
right he lives in texas so this
and of course they're asking now
they're asking him about the shooting
and the politicization of the shooting
yeah at uvalde at robb elementary high
school listen to his answer here and see
if you can make sense of this see that
it's a person willing that weapon you
know kane kia able you know and uh you
know and that's the problem that we have
and i said what we need to do is look
into how we can stop those things you
know they talked about doing a
disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at uh women that are
looking at uh just social media what
about doing that looking into things
like that and we can stop that you mean
something the fbi already does just
continue to talk about taking away your
constitutional rights and and i think
there's more things we need to look into
this has been happening for years and
the way we stop it by putting money into
the mental health field by putting money
into uh other departments rather than
departments want to take away your
rights
okay so uh
[ __ ] the word salad here
this is the folks i'm i want to give you
some really good news here this is the
absolute best that the republicans could
do in georgia
now this is this is one of the only
trump-backed candidates that won in
georgia something makes me think if you
looked at the primary makeup of the
republican primary in georgia game that
that democrats went and [ __ ] made
sure that herschel walker was the
candidate and all the other trump
candidates were not the candidates
because they figured those republicans
are going to win it's best not to like
at least these other people can form a
sentence you know right but this is all
the results of cte but i think they oh
this guy has been hit in the helmet one
too many times this guy what in the [ __ ]
was he talking about i don't know i mean
well he's an able and internet and
social media and he started off
department
what the [ __ ] are you talking about he
came out of the gate hard with uh with
the vibe right with the vibe right right
he was like listen guys straight to the
kate and abel two brothers one kill the
other we gotta we gotta we gotta prevent
this type of stuff
uh and then he goes into social media
and like monitoring social media and
it's like okay this seems like something
that we already have agencies that do
monitor for domestic terrorism and other
other threats that we have you know
within our country that's literally what
agencies like the fbi do okay that's
their job uh thank you for thinking you
thought of something new here
but
this this whole kind of word salad as
you said makes no [ __ ] sense i don't
know what he's talking about young girls
and boys and social media and
taking away your rights like
if someone if someone can be like a
herschel walker translator for us
i will give you a doubt that would be
great yeah if you could maybe five
dollars because we will probably hire
you again to translate
what that [ __ ] diarrhea word salad
was well here's what i said i said this
is the best they have i what the [ __ ]
what is this what the [ __ ] is he talking
about i i don't like
normally their nonsense
you know you can like pick it apart
you're like oh okay that's they're
saying that buzz word and that buzzword
and they're putting them in a certain
order right this guy it's almost like
he's got a list of words that he's
supposed to say and he's just shouting
them and he's trying to form sentences
in between them well he might have gone
up before the interview just like the
nra kind of prepped greg abbott to be
like okay listen i gotta hit points a b
and c make sure you don't talk about you
know say mental illness right yeah you
want it you want to go to bible verse
talk about you know this do this and as
long as you say those things that we'll
have a check ready to go a big fat check
ready to go when you show up to the nra
convention and give your speech and i
think the same thing happened here is
they went up to herschel walker and said
uh
look
you got to say these things don't say
these things uh say these other things
and he's like great got it and then he
went down and they're like
we never mentioned any of this stuff we
never even told you not to say the stuff
we never told you to say this stuff i
don't know where you got this from
the hell was it uh anita here from
facebook brings up a good point tony his
son had a video posted you mean my room
it is yes
if no one knows uh gabe has a um
and a relationship i guess if you call
it with um herschel walker's son
christian walker um where he he is his
uh imaginary virtual
roommate um and i mentioned it on the
show several times that gabe is
is christian walker's roommate um i
don't know is it a new video is it is
that what they're saying here
no i mean unless if i'm on his page
right now
are you
his page he's got a page yeah here i got
it here is he on is he where where is he
what is he it's on it's on instagram so
oh that's assuming
because he doesn't have a twitter
account right he can't no he does have a
twitter account he just blocked me on
all social media because he found out
that my videos that people were dragging
him with my videos
and that they were laughing to be like
this is what you said okay this is the
uh
his instagram stories okay so this is a
new video yeah these are new videos this
is 22 hours ago so you know what i'm
just going to download these videos
because
i'm sure
i will need them
does he ever delete videos off social
media
say again
does he ever delete videos off social
media uh sometimes he'll do a story and
then be like it's shareable now and it
you know some of these videos are like
wow that was a terrible take
but thank you for the uh
the material well let's see if i can
play this here let's let's uh
after we have all our facts together so
under two years ago the left was calling
for schools too and go back there we go
i just like to make sure we have all our
facts together so under two years ago
the left was calling for schools to give
up
their armed security because the left
didn't want police officers inside of
schools because the left hates cops no
because it doesn't work the country yeah
our kids have no secrets it actually
makes it worse
all of the people calling for us to give
up our second amendment right our
constitutional right to defend ourselves
well regulated right have armed security
outside of their homes and have armed
security at their workplace they live
inside of gated neighborhoods and then
they have an extra layer of protection
of pr what is this nonsense where
democrats and liberals i don't live in a
gated community i don't live in a gated
community either i don't know who does
who you know who does have that type of
i would almost be i would almost bet
that someone who is a son of a of a
football player and probably a
republican candidate for senate in
georgia he might he might he might he
might live in a gated community you know
who you know who else has protection and
actually who got protection passed who
did very quickly who's scotus oh because
some people were butt hurt that he had
some other people outside saying hey
you should not you should not be able to
decide what i do with my own body you're
talking loudly you're talking loudly
here and then they're like boom
within a few hours we had that bill
passed we had extra security for them
and their family members so don't come
at us with this [ __ ] democrats or
engaged communities with armed guards
this and that well the reason that we
don't have guards as we said earlier on
the show is because they don't [ __ ]
work in schools they actually make the
situation worse
it's like adding [ __ ] gasoline to a
fire you're an accelerant right making
it worse well here's what i tell you too
is is christian i know you got gay
blocked right i know i know you don't
like gabe because
your roommate isn't exactly on the same
page as you on some of these things but
but christian if you want to come on and
talk about some of this stuff i'll ask
you some very pointed questions they'll
be really easy for you to answer i'm
sure and if your dad would love to come
on and give me some of his word salad i
would love the chance love the chance to
pick apart
your dad's word salad but let's listen
to what [ __ ] has to say here private
armed security so law-abiding citizens
aren't allowed to defend themselves from
evil tyrants our kids have no security
but all of the people who want to take
away our rights they have their own
security all right pause it real quick
the hypocrisy is
this this i just want to point this out
this argument that i hear republicans
make of like you want to take away my
gun so that a tyrannical government can
come through and just kill me or like
try to do this and i i won't let the i
won't let the government do that i want
to have the ability to protect myself
listen man if the government wanted to
[ __ ] kill you they would kill you
when you wouldn't even know it they
would [ __ ] assassinate someone if
they really wanted to they would [ __ ]
they have [ __ ] tanks do you think
your [ __ ] nine millimeter your ar-15
will go up against a [ __ ] tank
no
well i mean it depends it depends on if
the good guys stand outside the school
and our yeah well here's what here's
what's gonna happen that good guy with
the gun that they think oh i'm defending
my second amendment rob the constitution
you're gonna get [ __ ] run over by a
[ __ ] tank like the people that are
like this [ __ ] gun is gonna stop the
government the government
what are you talking about
the government has its own military
sections of the government that are that
are
[ __ ] seal team six you got the
[ __ ] navy the air force the army like
all of these people are trained
and they could
do stop with your facts stop with your
facts christian here does not like facts
let's let's listen it's never ending i
don't want to hear
about your legislation goals when you
have taken away security from our
children and you're seeking to take away
our right to defend ourselves forget it
defend yourselves from who hollywood
celebrities i don't know
it just continues here with this
nonsense i can't take it anymore i hate
your roommate i [ __ ] hate your room
are they protecting themselves from your
roommate i just want to know tony such
an idiot i just want to know someone
said in the comments here gabe that
christian gives off a certain vibe
um well that's the other thing too
christian walker is part of the lgbtq
community mm-hmm right he's open right
he's oh yeah he's open yeah he's and and
someone like him who can openly support
a group that does not
actually acknowledge that community
how are you able as a person
to go against your own best interests
and support a party
who doesn't want you to have the same
rights as them
especially someone who's black
well you know there is a
there's another person
that is not part of that community who
really bashes that community a lot um
it's george shakai is part of the lgbt
community but this this tweet here is
about
nick fuentes we we talk about next week
fuentes is having his moment right so
george dakai here says well and and
george sakai light
rightfully goes after nick fuentes here
because of some of the [ __ ] that i'm
sure that nick fuentes's followers
[ __ ] say to george here
welp looks like alt-right leader and
he's a nazi nick fuentes i i did
george didn't say that i said the nazi
part because yeah nick isn't that no
nick i'm a nazi fuentest he's a [ __ ]
nazi is having a madison cother moment
look it up he says look it up i'm not
gonna tell you what it is
um we have our own video of that if you
would like to look it up
what the the uh madison gothard yes and
it is edited it is edited it is edited
it is it is safe for work oh subscribe
for work youtube channel if you go
subscribe to the youtube channel you
will find it on the youtube channel uh
the madison gawthorne video that we have
um and george continues to say here so
new term a cawthorne quote-unquote is
the length of time it takes you to be
exposed on film as a hypocrite so what
george is talking about here is nick
fuentes has been cawthorned as he says
now thank you george for your tweet by
the way
and uh so i seen this this morning and
i'm like what the what the hell
what the [ __ ] did nick fuentes do what
the hell is happening
so i decided to go look this up gabe and
apparently you know nip fuentes is uh
oh how do i put this he's a nazi so he
pretends to really
yeah yeah really hate on
gay people and non-manly men this is why
i also want to point out this is why you
do not
uh
try to do anything like rudy giuliani
showing his phone and being like i've
been in contact with these people and
he's like rolling through his ipad it's
like dude you you're you're giving
people evidence of you committing a
crime right also right do not show a
screen share of your phone unless you've
got that [ __ ] on lock right right this
is another example of that nick fuentes
did not have an unlock so this account
here at vhs archive post oh nick fuentes
what have you been watching and
bookmarking so nick fuentes apparently
sent out this screenshot let me pull it
back here a bit because he's he's
talking about the google down here at
the bottom it's it has his google
um
like his search terms i guess it's like
a um and he's trying to show his
statistics right yeah yeah and it's a
video so he does a video of his screen
and he's gonna show people
you know the
the evidence that he's popular right
well up here at the top you see this
little play button here and you see the
uh
the little play line like a youtube
video or like a pornhub video kind of
thing yeah and there's also a little
person doing there's also a little dot
here
that shows how far this video has been
watched now the videos uh it's the
evidence here that nick has put out is
five minutes and 28 seconds and it looks
like it looks like a porn video up here
is what it looks like i mean it looks
like somebody's mouth is on somebody's
oh whoa
i'm not going to uh click into this but
it does say here
um this video that apparently has been
outed it says
um t-girl sucking a fanboy's dick and
then he jerks until come so that's the
description of the video
that nick here on this post
apparently was watching
so
um i don't know if he was doing research
or what he was doing yeah i'm not really
here's the thing before before nick
fuentes opened his mouth and said
anything vile whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay i know i know i i guess i'm trying
to use my words uh
uh carefully here um
before he did that before he decided to
go on this attack on you know lgbtq and
just anyone who is not
white um you know here's the thing
i'm sure they would have accepted nick
fuentes like if he didn't have these
actual views he'd be like hey man this
is how you feel good that is you that is
who you are
but when you go against people
and you attack them and you make fun of
them you know
and then you get caught for this like
it's not surprising
because this party is full of projection
and accusation
and at the end of the day it's all just
a confession of something that they have
done or that they want to do
the same people who attack these groups
and want to take away their rights
are probably also people who would
identify in that group but don't feel
comfortable actually coming out in their
own party
and that's a sad real reality we live in
so let me let me for people who don't
know who nick fuentes is this is uh
outside a cpac moment where he's holding
a nazi rally america first rally you
guys remember the words america first
like uh america first nazis like matt
gatz and marjorie taylor green this is
nick fuentes outside a cpac event where
they won't let him in because he's just
a little too nazi for even the nazis and
uh this is we're nazi but that is way
too nazi
well listen listen to the nazi words
that come out of his mouth i'll be
giving my most unchanged speech ever
i'm off on twitter i have nothing to
lose
so this is gonna be the most racist
[Applause]
in all of dallas this weekend
i'll be giving my most all so this is
nick wentez people
and he's not even scared to admit that
he's a nazi so i mean it's not like i'm
saying anything here no he's we're just
giving the label to what he said right
he fits he checks all the boxes
well i mean you know
um nazi's gonna nazi that's for [ __ ]
damn sure
um
oh boy oh boy i i want to alert everyone
to this um in fact here we have put out
the own hint of the weak pole you guys
know we do bonehead of the week every
friday here um but gabe put up the bonus
of the week poll early this week because
it was obvious you our boneheads were
going to be yeah um and there's no no
beating it now right yeah yeah you're
not going to get around these three
being our boneheads you got senator
especially yeah they keep they keep
doubling down every single day he's
[ __ ] coward senator ted cruz texas
attorney general ken paxton and governor
greg abbott which all three of these are
complicit
um and they're they're really they're
really you know the gun the gunman
uvalde was not alone yet i mean he had
these three people helping him these are
still bad guys with the gun that's right
these are the bad guys with the gun ted
cruz ken paxton and greg abbott so if
you're looking for a list of people to
vote out of office here's a good start
if you're in texas here's a good start
if you're if you're a one issue voter
[ __ ] gop which reminds me tony you
have to post this on youtube
oh yes yes that is right and here's what
i'll tell you gabe here's what i'll tell
you before i came on the air i posted
this on youtube so go subscribe to our
youtube channel just type in the
tonymichaelspod and you will find this
poll not just on twitter but you will
also find it on youtube here's what we
do folks for all the new listeners out
there
we let you vote and you decide who is
the bonehead of the week between these
three [ __ ] ridiculous cowardly
boneheads
and then on friday in the second hour of
the show we break down your vote for
bone end of the week and we go through
why these are boneheads and we have
additions we have like this honorable
munch and alpha cuck and i'm sure those
will reveal themselves
um and the people that are saying can we
have uh a d all of the above no the way
that this the way that this poll is
designed is that you have to pick one
person it would be too easy for you to
say yeah all of the above because they
are in fact all [ __ ] boneheads right
well we would always we would always
have all the above like every single
time we would everything all the above
because we know they're all boneheads
yeah we know they're boneheads that's
why they're on the pole right
but we would end up having a poll where
it would be like 90
all of the above and then be like well
it's i mean we know that like the way
that the idea came is was you had to
pick one right and i know it's a tough
choice i know it's a tough choice but it
makes it too easy if you could just say
all of the above
so you have to really
you know put on that thinking right and
see who's the [ __ ] worst here who is
the worst it is difficult or the best
bonehead however you look at it it is
difficult uh to decide
but if you if you want to go over and
vote just uh follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod uh while you're there
follow at the tony michaels my account
and at i am gabe sanchez gabe's account
um because you're going to want to vote
for this either on twitter or
youtube you can vote in either place
because gabe not only do we do the
bonehead of the week in the second hour
on friday's show we also download it on
all the apple
all the podcasts apple spotify google on
sunday so we replay it on youtube
and we we put it on all the um the
directories for you to download the
audio so you definitely don't want to
miss bonehead of the week or the
opportunity to vote for bonehead of the
week
oh boy there's going to be there's a lot
of there's a lot of boneheadedness
um this week it it it is it is
it is tough to uh i mean every every day
is more revealing um you know i just i
just saw that uh
i'm reading on my phone right now but uh
joe garcia the husband of irma garcia
one of two teachers shot and killed in
uvalde texas on tuesday has reportedly
suffered a fatal heart attack joe and
irma were high school sweethearts and
married 24 years they leave behind four
children yeah geez
like don't don't
you know the people that are like oh
you know this is what happens you know
like you know it's uh it's not the gun
you know like
it's not just the event itself right the
people who try to justify it and say was
this it was the [ __ ] doors it was
mental health it was that whatever
like just realize
that what happens
has long-term effects
and this is an example of just one
person it's like the it's like the
capital police officer who had a heart
attack after the capital riot you're
going to tell me that these events don't
have a [ __ ] impact
we let people run wild in the streets
and try to overthrow the government and
wielding guns going pew pew wherever
they [ __ ] want
you don't think that's going to have a
long lasting effect if not an immediate
effect that has long lasting impacts on
those children
i thought you guys wanted to save the
children now these kids
i don't know what the situation is going
to have like if they're going to be
entered in the system in wards of the
state like they have family i i don't
know
but now because of one person
using guns that were legally purchased
and accessible because of people like
greg abbott and ted cruz and ken paxton
now they are the victims
not only did they lose one parent but
they lost both parents
it's sad it said and and and i tell you
there's a message out there from jimmy
kimmel he's been trending and the reason
why jimmy was trending is because of the
video that he did and i'm not going to
play a lot of it it's like eight minutes
long here uh well the reason he the
reason he posted is because it looks
like it was potentially cut off the air
in texas yes so so that i think that's
part of the story is that um not only
did he give this message and he actually
in the beginning he talks about how he
gave this message without an audience
and again i'm not going to play a lot of
it because what's going to happen is
youtube is going to make me silence it
because they're going to have a
copyright thing that's going to happen
which they own the copyright to it so
i'll have to turn it off on the actual
video um but i'll play just a few a few
seconds of it here to let jimmy uh kind
of queue it up to show you what this
video is about but there were places in
texas that were too snow flaky they just
couldn't handle jimmy kimmel's freedom
of speech are you listening out there
you freedom of speeches where are you at
you elon stands let's listen
hi it's jimmy and i wanted to speak to
you directly without
an audience for just a bit before we
start the show because here we are again
on another day of mourning in this
country once again we grieve
for the
little boys and girls
whose lives
have been ended and his families have
been destroyed
while our our leaders on the right the
americans at
congress and at fox news and
these other outlets warn us not to
politicize this
they immediately criticize our president
for even speaking about doing something
to stop it so i'm going to i'm going to
leave it there you guys definitely have
to go watch um this video
and again
you're watching on youtube um and it's
silent it's because they made me mute
the video because they do have copyright
to it i have retweeted it on my page but
you can just go to twitter and type in
jimmy kimmel you can probably go to
youtube and type in jenny jimmy kimmel
and find this video it's about nine
minutes long and it's worth the watch um
from beginning and i'm not saying you
know greg abbott called into the
stations and said hey you got to cut the
[ __ ] off or ken paxton said stop it
it looks like a dallas um yeah it
completely cut off like criminal media
control type [ __ ] and what katelyn says
which it's not not surprising that
they're so what happened to free speech
tony well you know these elon stands new
zealand stands really really got to have
their way about freedom of speech and
speaking of
i bet they were fine with this clip
though they were fine with sean hannity
rowing a list of children who were
killed for his profit watch this watch
this nonsense
in fact they don't even really seem to
care about gun violence at all
unless and until it fits a preferred
political narrative now take a look at
your screen since 2019 okay and then i'm
going to stop it there because i don't
want to believe the fact that he's going
to claim that we are just now
politicizing it or only using these key
events right
we have attempted to have these things
in place these protections these
measures in place to prevent this
every time it happens we have to go hey
guys this thing is waiting in the
[ __ ] wings for you guys to bring it
in and vote on it we're waiting for you
guys to actually act 90 of americans
support background universal background
checks for gun purchases regardless of
where are you on the spectrum you know
well here's the thing here's the thing
he's talking about bet o'rourke and how
he stormed the nra presser that greg
abbott held but what he failed to
[ __ ] realize is when outside that
presser there's another video
of beto talking about what you're
talking about like
we couldn't politicize it after this
event and it still happened and then
this event happened and you said not
politicize it and then this one happened
and this one happened and this one
happened when in the [ __ ] is the time
when is the time to [ __ ] politicize
this stuff when can we actually get to a
position where we can and folks
i'm telling you and i am going to tell
you and i'm going to keep telling you
make politics out of this at your
[ __ ] at your school at your community
center at your [ __ ] church at your
family's dinner make politics out of
this politicize the [ __ ] out of this
issue that's the only way we change this
the only way we change this is to elect
people who are willing to listen to us
for policy that's it that's it full stop
and it's not just with guns it's with
women's liberty it's with women's health
care it's with banning math in schools
and crt voodoo and all kinds of just
[ __ ] absolute nonsense that we have
to listen to from these [ __ ] gutless
cowards and these [ __ ] liars who are
bought and paid for by special interests
in this country like the nra the
federalist society and then on and on
and on it goes on and on these fascists
go and they won't stop so we can't stop
we cannot stop we have to continue we
have to keep going we have to keep
pounding this drum and we have to keep
politicizing these issues at every stop
and every measure don't stop
politicizing this stuff don't let them
[ __ ] shame you into oh you're
politicizing you're politicizing dead
child you goddamn
goddamn right i'm politicizing dead
children because if we don't there will
be more of them you want more stacks of
dead children in schools that's what you
want let's politicize the absolute [ __ ]
out of this now is the time it's not
time to sit back and be snowflakes and
whine and cry about policies that we
don't want because we aren't willing to
do the things to get those policies
which is to politicize these issues and
win these elections that is what i'm
going to do i'm going to keep yelling
and screaming this microphone every
single weekday two hours a day monday
through friday i'm gonna do it and i
don't give a [ __ ] no one's going to
silence me not elon musk nobody nobody
well i mean they might turn me off but
yeah i'll just go somewhere else i just
already turned off our super chat tony
dude they're trying to limit what we're
trying to do here no i know
i promise i've been working on this and
they said within 48 hours so hopefully
tomorrow hopefully tomorrow if not you
know it's [ __ ] we're gonna have greg
abbott coming after us well that might
be what it is it might be it might be
these uh these techs and republicans
trying to shut down our super chat so
that they can sign once us but they will
not silence me
they will not sign with me so tomorrow
uh everyone and make sure to tune in
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
come to youtube hopefully i will have
the super chat going youtube will have
to open up you know i got again i got an
email saying uh for maybe up to 48 hours
so if only super chat was as easy to
figure out and and obtain as it was an
ar-15 well that is true that is true too
bad too bad texans texan republicans
aren't regulating uh the super chat yeah
too bad too bad we'd already had it back
we'd already had it back thank you for
joining us thank you to all the new
listeners thank you for joining us out
there on youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
until tomorrow because we will be here
tomorrow just like we are every single
week every day don't forget to go vote
for bone end of the week it is up and it
is ready on twitter and youtube
but until tomorrow and maybe we'll talk
more about these boneheads tomorrow oh
100
until then
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking